hey guys this is dance the founder think
here and i'm david griffin your resident
comic book and video game guru and this
is our review of justified the season
five finale yeah episodes called
restitution yeah we haven't done any
reviews since the first few
not because i don't like the show i
actually love this show it's actually
one of my favorite shows i think it's
very underrated but
personally it's this show is hard to
watch one at a time i need to watch like
two or three of them kind of like
boardwalk empire where where all the
stuff does happen but you need to see it
in the context of like over a few
episodes yeah it's a slow build but this
was just such a strong season you know
just so many great elements with the
crow family moving from florida into uh
kentucky uh got some great moments with
boy crowder so i've always you know you
know i think agrees probably one of the
better characters on television
currently right now he's such a good
character played by walton goggins um
this show above many others such as a
great job with casting you know like you
said it's underrated which is too bad i
feel like you know this isn't one of our
more highly watched you know reviews on
think here not like a game of thrones or
walking dead of course whether it's good
or bad or shield even but i think it's
it's up there with the very best shows
on television that most people are not
watching those we don't watch most of
you like what kind of show is this who
is this oh it's that guy from
what you may call it like deadwood or
probably that would be what you know so
yeah some people don't know what dead
one is right yeah there's timothy yeah
or they see the cowboy hat they're like
is this a western it's like well it's a
modern western yes you know it's set
in today but it has a western feel to it
if you like shows about like you know
drug dealers you know prostitution like
all that kind of stuff but it's just set
kind of in a small country town in
kentucky you know it's it's good up your
alley all right so let's talk about the
big reveal i guess the setup for for uh
next season which is aver crowder being
released from jail and basically working
for raylen yeah i mean i think that's
the whole setup and it the show's gonna
end where it began i mean first episode
of the first season i believe you know
involved you know walton goggins
character and i mean of course they
almost were going to kill they were
going to kill him but they didn't
because they wanted to bring him back as
a fan reactions everybody loved him such
a good character and now i mean it's
going to end with those two guys going
at it because like raylen's about to
leave about to go see his wife natalie
zay who's you know busy with the
following and she's got a show on amazon
she's working on me she's she's just
like do a little like skype thing every
now and then she's like hey i'm still
here we have a daughter by the way about
to go to florida but then like oh wait
we're gonna go get you know boyd
crowders like oh hold on a minute you
know i'll stay here and do that so
i don't know i'm looking forward to it
but the same since i love walton goggins
character so much i love boyd crowder i
don't want to see want to see him
get killed
or go to jail for the rest of his life i
like them i want to see him be an outlaw
i just like that i don't know he's such
a good character
yeah also like you know when she first
got released i was like oh something's
up you know like they i'm pretty awkward
well when she got released it was so
because no one actually had done
anything i was like oh that's
she's working with for raylen and then
later at the end they show that i'm like
uh of course that makes more sense
because otherwise her just being
released randomly makes no sense
whatsoever right right i mean it was
i i like it but like i think it's just
man it's boyd i mean there's so many
good characters now uh boyd it looks
like is being offered by you know when
duffy to uh get into robbing banks it's
like i hear there is something you're
good at uh robbing banks so i mean maybe
that's what's going to be next season
maybe robbing banks we're gonna have
like a bonnie and clyde show off at the
end i don't know what's gonna happen but
uh it's gonna be interesting with her
ava kind of spoiled there's gonna be a
lot of tension gonna be because it's
like oh is she is boyd gonna find out or
not and is she gonna tell him and then
then put herself in trouble and who
knows and and braylon all he wants to do
before he leaves is get boyd crowder
into jail right they're saying boyd
crowder's at the center of everything
um
i don't know that's interesting i mean
he doesn't want him dead because he
could have killed him many times oh yeah
really well they were childhood friends
yeah i mean they grew up together ryan
just took a different path but i mean
whenever they're on screen together
those are some of the best moments in
the show and i i'm just i'm sad i know
that's going to we're going to have to
let it go next season's the final season
but i'm going to miss it
how do you like i thought like with boy
crowder and especially in this episode
it was probably in the most danger he's
ever been in
yeah yeah because i felt like oh man
those guys from mexico are going to kill
him right because he always talks about
that silver tongue he has
and it took his wits to do the quick you
know text messaging and changing you
know
um daryl
yeah to pretend that it's daryl right
and so i mean he had to use his wits
because he's trying to charm those guys
and that was fun when the mexicans they
turned around they're like i've been to
vegas like six times or so i mean
they're like trying to be like like
these guys are like from some third
world country or something but i'm glad
that happened because otherwise it would
have been cheesy if they actually fell
for it it'd be like really i'm like we
got especially living out here in l.a
man people travel all over the place no
one's like not not been to vegas if you
live in this corner of the world not
even that just to turn
their allegiance so it's gonna be too
easy too easy and there's repercussions
you can't just be like oh i'm gonna
right you know
kill this other guy you don't think
people from mexico aren't going to come
in oh they'll come out yeah and i love
the shootout at the end had a lot of
great tension um i thought it was just
great i mean the only thing again with
justified i wish i wish i'd use the two
supporting deputies more than just like
hey we got the girl and the guy like
they just really don't do anything like
even when she was um promoted to a
temporary deputy or temporary you know
the chief temporary chief well what's
his name was in the hospital he didn't
really feel much for her because they
just don't know anything about their
character but i mean that's just how the
show's always been they're just railing
sidekicks they don't really have much
character yeah and i think she's
probably going to take over at the end
because art's retiring yeah she got shot
so eventually she's going to be maybe
next season
but i mean because
we know that raylen is leaving in a
quote-unquote a few weeks
that next season is going to take place
over a few weeks yeah because he wants
to get this done before
before he's transferred because we're
i'm pretty sure the end of the
season
or at the end of the series is him going
to florida yeah it's not one of those
shows where i would see him dying no it
just wouldn't fit the show's profile
like i just don't has he even really
been
injured he's been i think shot maybe
once yeah but i don't i couldn't see him
i i don't know i hope not
because i mean he's got a kid he hasn't
even really seen that much so he gets to
see his kid again
um yeah one of the main reasons too that
i like this season was the whole
crow family
with daryl dewey running off
uh
wendy wendy her son slash little brother
yeah weird yeah i really like the
dynamics of that and and
you know we got to see raylen's dark
side yeah you know because he didn't
kill daryl but when he was dying he
taunted him he taunted him he went over
his body he's like hey like i told you
you wish you'd want me to kill you and
what's funny with raylen is i mean he's
a martial he's just has to do what he
has to do but he's just a stone cold as
any of those criminals oh he does some
dark stuff yeah i love like he has that
conversation with the kid you know about
like you know the first time you kill
something it's not easy not an easy
thing to do to take a life but i mean
he's pretty stone stone-cold i mean he
can kill basically anything he doesn't
seem like he feels that much emotion
about it anymore and he's willing to go
to certain lengths to
get the job done
i mean even just the whole getting the
judge to charge
the kid as a as an adult
that's a gamble that's a gamble because
he doesn't know if
you know the the kid's gonna decide to
confess the truth or wendy's gonna help
him out but
right and i think even last season with
you know why art and railing were such
odds this season you and art punched him
in the face you know after the
realization of what he had done to take
down those detroit guys i mean that's a
railing goes to you know goes above the
law to do what he needs to do because he
believes i think in justice not just not
just the law he was justified yeah
it's not the law right he wants justice
right yeah he believes in justice over
the law right he's like you know like he
told like he said at the end of dude
he's like you're gonna wish you would
have killed me or no you wish don't you
wish i would have killed you instead of
this happening instead of you being
killed by your own sister it's like the
most humiliating way and not only that
shot in the balls and then right through
the neck yeah
pretty much bad way to go not a good way
to go and he you know he wrote it out
that wendy it was self-defense when
yeah kind of rails got a soft spot he's
got a soft spot for the ladies he's got
a soft spot
all right so yeah i thought this season
was great i i thought yeah best in
season two season two is still my
favorite right but this is this is up
there yeah this is really good i mean
margo martindale basically introduced
this whole like villain of the season
every season now like since two is like
a villain of the season and this this
this one was one of the best since then
so the second season yeah all right guys
so that's what we thought of uh the
justified season five finale you can
post your comments below on the website
thinkhero.com or on our youtube channel
think hero pro make sure to subscribe to
that way you can check us out on twitter
you'll talk to us about justified if
you've never checked it out before i
highly recommend it like dennis and i
said it's a very underrated show you can
find us at think hero i'm at griffinde
we also have a facebook page that's
facebook.com thinkhero fans and make
sure you like that page and share our
videos on twitter and facebook and all
that stuff thanks